un estado utilizado como arma de
represión contra su población así
resumido Naciones Unidas la forma en que
el gobierno nicaragüense ha tratado a
sus ciudadanos desde que en 2018 una
protesta ciudadana estalló en contra del
presidente Daniel Ortega y su esposa a
la vicepresidenta Rosario Murillo se
trata de un informe realizado por una
misión en el país que resalta una
multiplicidad de crímenes de lesa
humanidad cometidos de manera
sistemática
estas violaciones y abusos se perpetran
de manera generalizada por motivos
políticos y constituyen crímenes de lesa
humanidad de asesinato encarcelamiento
tortura incluida la violencia sexual
deportación y persecución por motivos
políticos también identificó ejecuciones
extrajudiciales realizadas por agentes
policiales y miembros de grupos
paramilitares durante las protestas de
2018 el informe concluyó que el
presidente Ortega y la vicepresidenta
Murillo han puesto en funcionamiento
estos crímenes y que muchos de estos
siguen ocurriendo
sino realizando a través de reformas
constitucionales legales y de una u otra
manera frente a procesos en donde se
ejecutaron de manera coordinada con
diferentes estructuras del Estado
acciones que fueron sistemáticas y
generalizadas dentro de un ataque que
implica violaciones y crímenes de toda
índole en los últimos años son miles los
opositores que han tenido que abandonar
el país en medio de la represión al
menos 3.144 organizaciones de la
sociedad civil han sido clausuradas y
casi todos los medios independientes
operan en el exterior pero la situación
empeora con el tiempo en el último mes
las autoridades despojaron de su
nacionalidad a más de 200 personas
acusadas de ser traidores a la patria